[Music]
will smith has resigned
from the [ __ ] academy man
what what is that exactly what i mean
what does it do does that mean you have
to get any more oscars
no he can get more answers you can't
vote he can't
he can't he can't get any more screeners
anymore yeah wait the academy is the
oscar what position was he in that he
resigned from actor
he was he was a he was a member of the
academy of motion picture art and
science i didn't know you can resign
from that doesn't that mean so that's
kind of like let's say if you're sag
right and you give up your sad card does
that mean you can't win the sad guild
awards anymore you still can but you you
just don't get any of the screeners i
think it's screeners and you don't get
you don't get to vote on on like what
wins right you can't vote isn't that a
perk of the academy do you feel like
that they they were voting are all
actors that vote a lot like it's just
random people there
so that's how will smith wants because
his peers elected him because of the
vote
yeah so he doesn't have to give his
oscar back
he does not what do you think he does
without all his screeners back this year
yeah
destroy all the dvds
this is not for commercial use yeah
screening only like we get it those are
so fun to [ __ ] download screeners
weren't they yeah you're like oh it's a
screener he's going to be high quality
because it's near the oscars the
screeners are fire
do you think he won an oscar for fresh
prince of bel-air no he didn't actually
no that was his first answer this
morning he can't write it has to be an
emmy right yeah not for french not for
fresh prince because oscar's all movies
right yeah yeah so like it has nothing
to do with that i know bart how do you
feel about will smith and what he did
about what all right about what am i i
don't know do you support him
i forgot we moved on i watched it yet
about what forget it trust me i'm going
to videos
i'm going to get to it
oh i love the movie
bart's gotta watch bright too first
i'm gonna watch that no i'm gonna watch
the slap
first and then there's a lot of other
ones where like chris rock fights back
and all that there's a lot of remakes
and you know you haven't even seen the
slap i want no i'm gonna say
it's a one minute video
i have a kid i have a kid dude i don't
have a title it's [ __ ] tyka's fault
he doesn't it's not his wall his tiger's
full tiger should slap you
no he i won't even get it i don't even
know where that came from
all right well how do you feel about
romelu bronx with a when they the guy
said our boss is not white tiger how do
you say taika feels about rumble in the
box
so he likes it yeah but seriously how do
you feel about uh the the whole
situation because i talked about it man
i thought so if you hear my thoughts um
i thought it was wrong for him to slap
him
wrong as a mind of violence you think
it's wrong
there's just so many layers to it right
like one everyone's in hollywood
everyone's homies like if someone got
something if you really felt some way
about how someone talked to your chick
talk to them behind the scenes that's
number one number two you're a comedian
first too
so
from that angle like come on you gotta
you gotta defend comedy and
and what you gotta say like no matter
what that's what kevin sorbo did i'm
like we should all we should all defend
comedy before our wives
i'm like dude come on kevin sorbo did
that of course he did and i'm like
so like you're a comedian with with the
show come on dude comedians always will
yeah and then number three i don't know
where kevin
if you slap chris rock for that you
better shoot august
right like or your [ __ ]
your thing
and this is coming from a fan too i
[ __ ] love
does i love bad boys i always told you
guys will smith sucks
this comes from a fan and as a fan you
like execute this mom partner no no no
no i just don't i don't i i don't know
what he's going to probably going
through some [ __ ] but jade is the
problem i don't uh condone
his actions and also
coming from someone that also lived in
the hood before
you don't escalate [ __ ] you know like if
it's just talking you talk but if you
escalate to physical if chris rock was
from the hood and he has his homies
shoot you on the streets
expect that yeah like if you want to
expect that if you want to escalate [ __ ]
that's on you man because he just used
words and if you're gonna use physical
violence then you opened up the
pandora's box now anything i would take
that as a challenge to a duel isn't it
not fair because like
dude if any of our tricks was getting
[ __ ] railed on and i got to sit there
the the
any joke like comedy railed on no no
we're trained randall physically right
now
yeah like having a sex on like august
august [ __ ] yeah like august okay
like penis is going in our [ __ ] yeah
i i think there's no way that you could
make fun of my chick and me not be like
i'm not a [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah for real for real
but that's the reaction that's the
reaction so that's the [ __ ] things
it's a pride thing for him exactly like
he's been getting [ __ ] on yeah so
hard and i feel like nigeria
exactly and the other thing that i'm
trying to say here's the other thing
though here's before you get to that
point here's the thing okay let's say
that's that's how it really feels
if you know a comedian is hosting the
oscars in
like don't sit in the front row of the
comedy show but they're the most famous
people sit in the back because you know
if you're on the front row of a comedy
show you're getting roasted on no matter
who you are yes that is the shamu splash
zone sure for sure
but nobody wants to sit next to john
leguizamo
no i'm a fan i love the movie the best
by the way
he's the greatest luigi of all time
but like nobody wants to sit come on he
was really good on spawn though he was
he was spoiled
right now last night what's your point
now uh well i was saying about like
everybody knew about their whole
situation of her [ __ ] everyone
because
she was the one that i was kind of
putting out but
and the way that she like started
salivating when she was talking about
like oh yeah and she was like pretty
much saying like you're born and [ __ ]
whatever but anyways but then for like
will smith we all knew he was [ __ ]
too but we like i feel like we've never
heard
never had of them
and i feel like what she did was like
kind of like turning the knife okay into
the dude even more so then by the time
at the academy awards and when that
thing happened he just probably couldn't
take it anymore the part that i don't
quite get i don't know if you guys talk
about this is we did so chris ross we
did says we covered it yeah the the
whole gi j2
talked about that the first thing you
see the first thing no the first thing
is will smith toy
and then he looks to jada right and then
jada gives her the death eyes dude she
hits them with the whole and we all know
that look and then all of a sudden i'm
like dude
your true first reaction was haunting
come on dude we all know that look and
we all been there yep
then that's when you say i got diarrhea
and you go in the bathroom and you just
stay there the rest of them that's the
time to say it
i got diarrhea
that's why i'm laughing it says
i got diarrhea
you gotta react this move that he's
doing like resigning from whatever and
do you think he's gonna go to the ward
show or do you think like
like is he gonna continue to go i think
that he did this to neutralize their
response so like whatever they do they
can't not gonna kick him out now because
he just won the oscars like next year
he's gonna present the oscar for best
male actor i heard he's pretty bummed
about the screeners though
that's what i heard yeah that was one of
the main stories
how am i going to use my dvd player now
they should be digital i don't have a
dvd player anymore can we figure this
the [ __ ] out and they're like nah dude
let's learn yeah yeah
damn that's crazy though just the amount
of i think he already had that negative
attention
and then through the slap
[ __ ] cranked it up by a hundred i
just feel like he's going through a lot
right now i feel bad for the guy
i did
i i actually did i really do feel bad
for will in a way yeah but then i
remember pre-oscars
yeah yeah for sure
but then i remember like all the gifts
he gave my childhood and like how sick
he was and everything that he was in and
i was just like oh he was just more like
he was when he's younger and i wish
somebody would just tell him that yeah
and that'd be helpful commentary that's
that's actually very honest thing
because when you say that i do think
about the actual influence that will for
the will smith had
huge on everybody
i wish people could just tell him that
because it was really easy back then but
he makes it so hard
but like back then it was like
it's hard to love a simp
yeah but i feel like he's a lovable simp
i think he's just with the right he's
also a symp that's banging all kinds of
other chicks anybody
to the point where he vomits he yeah he
would come and then throw up dude that's
how much he could in that order it was
in his book that's like binge eating
yeah he was he was busting he was
busting it down so much blowing [ __ ]
wads
and he wasn't men in black
another iconic remember the scene where
he's trying to like do his test and he's
like moving yeah my favorite scenes ever
will today when you look into when you
look at will today and you see his
interviews or anything right it looks
like he's been crying in the back room
seriously and then he got and then he
just
got himself composed and he came on and
i'm like those are tears of cries on
your eyes those red eyes of cries
that's the name of the next movie he
cries a lot now right and i was like
what's going on tyson but yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm cries in like seven pounds he
cries in the pursuit of happiness he
cries in i am legend
and bright i thought in the flashy thing
the flashy thing
the flashy thing flashes youtube
was really good let me tell you
something mike tyson [ __ ] is
professional he's wise
mike tyson not the same one this is what
he said
yeah
why was his hand open should have closed
it yeah it's much harder you should have
smashed this one where they're like
muhammad ali taught
um will smith how to throw a good hook
and i was thinking wait this article is
like trying to say like he [ __ ] used
a solid hook punch for this and i'm like
he
he he was a limp wrist slapper
when when will learned from him muhammad
was like 82. and shaken yeah
so
i don't know how effective that slap was
exactly chris
rock took it like pretty good you know
sometimes though it's not about how like
strong something is right it's like if
somebody were to come up and like punch
you that's one thing that might offend
you so much but if somebody came up and
slapped you because that might that
might offend you more
oh yeah i mean that's humiliating it's
kind of like the slap around the world
type of thing yeah i would have cried
because all i would have said i thought
you were my friend i feel bad for both
of them because i do really like both i
love chris rock
i don't care about will anymore yeah but
i love chris rock me too like the fact
that he well he came back from that
[ __ ] good though which is great like
he was like
we'll just slap the [ __ ] out of it he
got laughed at the show he got left
continued the show finished his job
carrie said he was like yeah he's like i
would sue him for like 400 million
dollars because like
that video will live on for forever dude
that was crazy
listen to jim carrey talk about it too
really jim carrey was really upset about
it since i watched that [ __ ]
documentary where jim carrey's like
tells the daughter of andy kaufman like
i'm andy kaufman like in real life i
lost my respect for him there but i
gained it back through this because he
was like hey look hollywood's [ __ ] up
they had no spine they didn't tell him
to leave they didn't say like go [ __ ]
off standing o yeah standing so real
rewarding yeah statue instead
i wish everyone would have just said
like yo
what the [ __ ] and then
like didn't reward him for it actually
like made consequences happen but he
didn't think hollywood would ever have
the ball i felt like if someone like
andy dick or something what up and slap
chris rock i thought you would get
tackled by security guards
yeah he would get piledrived on the
stage chris yeah
yeah i'm like the amount of respect and
i guess like favoritism they played
towards him
crazy definitely because if any one of
us did it we'd not only get kicked out
dude we get [ __ ] locked up
imagine if good ol seemu he was over at
the oscars right our very own cimu he
just got his foot in the door in
hollywood
and he walked up and slapped the [ __ ]
out of chris rock and will smith yeah
and he said ten [ __ ] rings
[ __ ] like whatever right they
would've
right then and there huffed his ass
asian hated his ass sent the moth to
[ __ ] rikers all his cash was gone
everything
stripped him of the title first asian
man
all that [ __ ] and that's how unfair
hollywood is he's the first asian man
the first first public one jacket he's
the first letterman first asian man dude
[Music]
huh
[Music]